bonsoir le palmarès du festival de
cannes a réservé quelques surprises
contre toute attente la palme d'or a été
décerné au film amerrika pulp fiction
qui couronne le jeune réalisateur
quentin tarantino qui signe là seulement
son deuxième film globalement on
constate que le jury a tenté
d'équilibrer les récompenses la france
s'en sort plutôt bien
en recevant trois prix l'impôt grosse
fatigue des michel blanc et les deux
autres pour la reine margot de patrice
chéreau stars paillettes émotions cécile
barnier un palais des festivals plaque
raqueter le vent dame du cinéma en habit
d'or pour présenter la soirée
ovation pour jeanne moreau subtil en
maîtresse de cérémonie probation
également pour la très célèbre vice
président du jury catherine deneuve et
pour le non moins célèbre président du
même je vais l'outil soude
la cérémonie peut commencer il me semble
que j'entends le battement au point le
coeur qui a probablement battu le plus
fort celui de la meilleure actrice
virmani
l'interprète de catherine de médicis
dans la reine margot de patrice chéreau
merci à mon directeur patrice chéreau et
merci à catherine de médicis que c'est
une femme tellement incroyable qui m'a
plu il m'avait avoir 7 merci beaucoup de
l'émotion et un autre pour patrice
chéreau la reine margot le prix du jury
mais rien pour isabella jane de
l'émotion et quelques bafouillages
allège les hommes céramique de chiara
mastroianni inquirer l'attention sur tel
ou tel aspect j'appelle désapprobateur
de sa mort
la france très présente au palmarès
michele norsa grosse fatigue repartent
avec le prix du scénario
un prix qui n'avait pas été attribués
depuis dix ans le prix de la mise en
scène revient nanni moretti pour son
journal intime
le grand prix du jury est attribué
ex-aequo à soleil trompeur du russe
mikhal cov et à vivre deux ongs limoux
un film censuré par les autorités
chinoises tour réalisateur n'a pas pu
venir à cannes un film qui obtient
deuxième prix celui du meilleur acteur
et voici le moment tant attendu la palme
d'or au peuple américain
si nos univers de malpas un humour noir
une palme d'or surprise pour un
réalisateur provocateur mais nous
reviendrons encore avec plus de détails
donc sur ce palmarès après journal jean